toc toc toc qui est là Giroud giroqué
Giroud au bout de mes rêves
tout au bout de mes rêves
[Applaudissements]
j'y vais direct à toi
merci ça fait ça fait plaisir de te
retrouver ah c'est joli
tu peux quand même je m'en fous
franchement je m'en fous de là ça tombe
bien parce que moi aussi
non vraiment non mais c'est important de
le dire ça tombe bien moi aussi donc on
va ça va tu peux nous parler
je suis heureux j'ai pris un peu de
couleur et je remercie tous les gens
pour tous les messages qui m'ont envoyé
ça m'a fait du bien ça m'a fait chaud au
coeur merci beaucoup d'être là c'est
gentil merci
[Applaudissements]
attention prochain toc toc toc c'est
parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et bien demain
à partir de à partir de mercredi
ce soir à partir de mercredi vous savez
rappelez il y avait Paul le poulpe lors
de la dernière Coupe du Monde qui
donnait ses pronostics et bien moi
j'aurais rare Raphaël qui sera avec nous
donnera ses pronostics à partir de
mercredi j'appellera Raphaël je fais sa
connaissance ce week-end sur les quais
on a tout de suite sympathisé oh mais
c'est vrai on s'adore maintenant on
n'arrête pas on sait on s'est rongé tous
les deux
et non mais c'est vrai et donc à partir
de mercredi à Raphaël fera ses
pronostics sur la Coupe du monde donc
Rafael sera la mercredi voilà là
aujourd'hui il pouvait pas parce qu'il
est il est en date
c'est vrai voilà il est sur un bail mais
il sera là mercredi comment va beneym
elle va très bien alors je sais que je
sais que ce weekend en plus patoche
n'était pas là votre amoureux j'étais
seul et ouais et lui et lui il peut
savoir où il était il était en Jordanie
parce que je sais que pas tout Fatou
était en Jordanie aussi donc
il y avait pas tout et Fatou non non
c'est vrai non non il est avec qui il
était il faisait en fait un trek vous
savez il courait dans le désert
quand même un très grand sport c'est le
seul mec qui revient d'un truc avec 3 kg
de plus
non mais écoute moi c'est pas grave
sur leur dossard ils ont des des petites
puces GPS pour les voix
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
en tout cas très fort très fort ce qu'il
a fait allez prochain toc toc c'est
parti toc toc non non
on a reconnu la voix
on sait que c'est Gilles Verdez et
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on démarre la
semaine avec toi Gilles franchement
alors vas-y refais le tac tac tac qui
est là c'est Harry
kaneki Harry Connie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu es ridicule
non pas du tout l'Angleterre qui a gagné
tu verras Raphaël ah oui j'ai entendu
génial super oui oui
Sébastien c'est Patrick Sébastien tiens
d'ailleurs j'ai vu Patrick Sébastien il
s'est coupé les cheveux ah bon ah mais
il est magnifique j'ai croisé la
dernière fois au restaurant magnifique
c'est coupé
il s'est coupé comment je peux Jean-Marc
magnétis en plus donc il a fait un petit
dégradé comme ça avec une sur le côté il
était magnifique je dis comme ça je l'ai
vu je suis junior
magnifique hein Patrick Sébastien
magnifique et ben il a il y a plus du
tout cette coupe par contre toi tu peux
enlever ce que tu angoisses tout le
monde merci allez toc toc toc
qui est là c'est Jordy
le joueur le joueur s'appelle Jordi Alba
sinon ça marche pas
[Rires]
ça il faut dire c'est qui c'est Jordy
Alba albaki
donc ça marche pas si vous dites c'est
Jordy genre dit qui Albator on comprend
pas
repartez là-bas vous reviendrez tout à
l'heure quand vous aurez compris
[Rires]
je vais la nuit il peut faire très peur
la nuit tu te réveilles tu le vois tu as
mal vu tu sais pas qui c'est
tu peux croire dès que lui il te sourit
dans la nuit pour faire très très peur
et petit pour faire peur oh bah tu sais
bah
méfie-toi allez toc toc toc j'espère que
c'est quelqu'un qui a compris le jeu
[Musique]
non non alors le joueur pas vrai le
joueur non le jour le joueur s'appelle
Manuel Neuer c'est le gardien de
l'équipe d'Allemagne alors on voit
qu'ils disent des noms ils disent des
choses qui ne comprennent pas donc tu as
compris donc tu dois dire c'est qui
c'est Manuel Neuer Manuel Neuer
[Applaudissements]
c'est quand même un monde non mais qui
m'a foutu des bras cassés pareil en mode
alors vas-y on la refait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et je disais que tu es je disais que tu
étais de plus en plus belle je ne rigole
pas à qui à mes parents
ça c'est une preuve de générosité
ou bien peut-être veut-elle s'en
débarrasser
on va on va prendre la première solution
tu as toujours eu beaucoup de chance
piscine ou rien en fait
non mais je m'ennuie jamais moi
un peu de ménage un peu de ouais j'ai
profité de maman
tu sais que ta maman je l'aime beaucoup
heureusement et tu connais mode c'est un
rayon de soleil
franchement remonter content de voir
mode ah c'est un rayon de soleil
vous allez dire que j'abuse
tu es content de voir Maud j'adore c'est
un rayon
[Rires]
on enchaîne allez Géraldine bien chérie
ça marche pas comme ça non
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
son prénom et Maud est un rayon de
soleil
Jean-Marie Bigard j'attends de savoir si
il va comprendre le jeu
on arrête d'ailleurs le laisser pour la
fin
tiens rappelez
[Applaudissements]
on peut écouter le son s'il vous plaît
écouter le son s'il vous plaît
quel moment vous en connais de la
guitare
[Rires]
ce que je connaissais pas cette musique
on m'a dit c'est une musique des années
x j'ai dit ok je connais pas j'ai écouté
ça fait 1h
c'est un rayon de soleil
c'est Lukaku
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
on dirait vraiment un gars qui existent
non mais on dirait un gars qui est
vraiment la Coupe du monde mais vraiment
c'est que toi tu passes là tu passes
partout c'est le nouveau préparateur
physique
mais attends mais c'est éditeur le
nouveau préparateur je ne peux plus
meublée non mais incroyable vous avez
l'enfant de la pub Kinder je peux te
dire un truc
c'est juste un petit collage je te le
colle et puis c'est pour ça marqué parti
pour de moi hein
ça te va hyper il a pris des pecs hein
[Rires]
d'abord Mathieu
Delormeau s'il se souvient de moi
Christian Messi
raconte
Cristiano Ronaldo et c'est Lionel Messi
donc un problème
de connexion
tu vois pas que tu es en train de faire
passer pour un con merci Lionel
j'entends mais non allez vas-y c'est
Richard richardo un homme
c'est pour un con parce que j'ai des
fans allez vas-y allez ok ça repart 3 2
1 toc toc qui est là Ricardo merci
[Applaudissements]
ta gueule
[Rires]
merci maman merci maman merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon cœur aussi
mal mais il a bossé comment ça va bien
pourquoi tu cries
non j'ai une question parce que la
production à louer tout ça et celui-là
soit qui me va très bien parce que tu
m'autorises à partir avec je te l'offre
[Applaudissements]
vas-y tu as compris
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Cristiano Cristiano
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon chéri je pense que tu vas pas me
demander de le garder toi celui-là
du Portugal j'adore cette équipe mais on
va te trouver mieux
je suis d'accord aussi
je suis super content je suis en
sandwich avec les filles c'est bien
tu as suivi un peu le début de
l'émission
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
si tu devais la comparer je sais pas moi
je dirais
les toilettes
un rayon de soleil bien sûr